it is November 1st 2023 so it's time for
another monthly update video in which
I'll tell you about all the cool stuff
that we've got coming up in the month of
November and all the things you might
have missed from the long month of
October which we've just finished up I
always like to begin by highlighting
three big things so here they are big
thing number one Scott truli and I are
resuming offering a monthly classic
metal class and we've got some cool
topics already lined up for this month
and the coming months big thing number
two in October we had the
International stoicon Conference I gave
a talk which I'll link to below you also
see a card here for that about about
objects of beauty that stoics talk about
in their Works big thing number three in
the study with Sadler Academy also
linked to below I am going to be rolling
out some new online classes that I'm
very excited about and a lot of people
have been asking for and are excited
about as well so those are the big
things let's talk now about the month of
October October was a pretty busy month
I had four classes that I was teaching
still teaching all the way up to
December uh at Marquette University and
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
but I did a lot of events as well we
kicked off the month with my usual ask
me anything session had a lot of great
conversation there uh I mentioned that I
got to speak at the internet
International stoicon and you can see
that uh link to below along with the AMA
and we held our worlds of speculative
fiction session on enk gon's wonderful
broken Earth Trilogy some really great
sci-fi SL fantasy novels um I also did a
sort of
celebratory video about the saders
lectures pod
reaching the Thousand episodes Mark uh
that's kind of a cool Milestone to hit
um we also had several wisdom for Life
Radio Show episodes come out which you
can see the videos for as well one of
which had to do with the half-hour Hegel
project which I finished uh back earlier
in the fall and the other of which had
to do with some questions that people
had about stoicism since it's the you
know month for stoicon and stoic week is
coming up this month so a lot of cool
events um I did a lot of video work as
well I got two book reviews done
something I've been wanting to get to
for a while uh Julian beIN the great
guide which is about David Hume and
philosophy as a way of life Martha nbel
anger and forgiveness a book that I use
as a textbook to which I gave a somewhat
mixed review
um I also did some uh videos about uh
you know narrative Sadler stories videos
mostly about fall related things and I
also did a more personal video uh about
life lessons that I have been mauling
over because I've been dealing with some
health challenges as of late some of you
may know this from my uh social media
that I have a gall bladder issue that's
taking a while so you know thinking
about getting older things going wrong
with your body how to keep yourself from
you know falling into depression or
despair or things like that I did a
video specifically about that I also did
something that I've been wanting to do
for a while a calling out fake quotes
video about Marcus tulus Cicero some of
the most egregiously fake quotes that
people bring up um I I I did a couple
oneoff videos as well about some great
uh speculative fiction authors one about
Ursa Kay Len and her recent essay from
2017 about anger and I also did a really
cool video uh enk
gemson uh a one-off video about her um
response to Ursula Kaya green called
Ursula kayen did a um a short story
those who walk away from Moss enk gson
wrote a short story those who stay and
fight so that was kind of interesting
and then you know I've been editing
things from an Aristotle class that I
did over the summer some bonus session
footage that I've uh let people you know
check out those are getting some good
play and comments and then the biggest
thing that I've been doing video wise is
I started uh a series and I did 13
videos in the series so far of core
concept videos on Emmanuel con proma to
any future metaphysics so we've gotten
through the first part of it and we've
got a lot more yet to come so people are
getting uh you know quite happy to to
see those videos out in the saders
lectures podcast interestingly enough
I've released a lot of podcast episodes
and they're all on one t text
Aristotle's categories another big text
that many people have difficulties with
and so I thought it would be useful to
bring those out for students um as I
mentioned I'm still teaching my academic
classes I have a full load this semester
of four classes four different classes
two of which are at Marquette University
two of which are Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design got a significant client
load you know doing tutorials philosoph
iCal counseling some Consulting work um
and I've been you know continuing to
volunteer at almost home cat shelter and
to work on Grant work for them as well
it's a really great cat shelter and I'm
going to put in a pitch here you know if
you want if you got a couple extra bucks
and you're looking for a place to make
an impact um almost home is always going
to have good uses for the money mostly
for veterinary bills that turns out to
be the biggest cost for these these cat
shelters because they take really good
care of these these you know abandoned
lost um uh you know fostered out cats so
that's part of what's been going on I
mentioned that I've been dealing with
some health issues but I'm trying to
keep a upbeat attitude about that easier
some days than than others so that is
the month of October which here in
Milwaukee
finished with a heavy snowfall on
Halloween all right what is coming up in
the month of November we've got a lot of
events packed into this month we begin
this Saturday the 4th at noon with the
AMA that's ask me anything session so
anybody can show up and we do a live
streaming I answer as many questions as
I can get to in 90 minutes sometimes go
over a little bit you want to get your
questions in early because we never do
get to all of them it's just you know
impossible there's so many of them to
get to uh the same day for patreon
supporters who are pledging at a certain
level uh of support I have a philosophy
chat that's a much more uh indepth and
intimate Zoom
conversation that you're welcome to join
in on if you if you'd like to become a
supporter of my work
um on the 6th that's a Monday through
the 12th we have international stoic
week this is an opportunity to learn how
people in fact do practice stoicism this
this philosophy as a way of life uh try
out some exercises I do it every year
even though um you know I've been doing
it for for a very long time and I teach
people about that I think it's a great
opportunity to retool and if you don't
know much about stoicism and you want to
learn about it well then you want to
check that out um on the 8th here in
Milwaukee well actually in and mecan uh
in the greater Milwaukee area we've got
an in-person
event so if you're in the area and you'd
like to learn more about David Hume I
will be giving a talk at 6 pm at the
Frank wanberg library in the
philosophers in the midst of history
series and we'll record it as well so
you if you you know you're not in the
area you can at least watch it later on
but if you are in the area and you want
to see me uh speaking live great
opportunity to do so um on the uh 11th
at noon that's a Saturday we will be
having the next worlds of speculative
fiction series session and this is going
to be devoted to a big fan favorite
Terry pratchett's discor series we're
looking at five of his disc World novels
all of which have to do with the
character rincewind who's a wizard but
not much of a wizard but turns out to be
very important to the fate of the disor
universe that begins at noon we have
about roughly 90 minute to to you know
120 minute video with live chat uh we do
a Premiere and then we have a zoom
session to continue the conversation for
those who are interested then on the
18th the next Saturday I mentioned this
as one of the three big things Scott
truli and I are going to restart classic
metal class and that is a zoom session
Scott and I will be presenting we'll be
taking questions and comments from
people on the side and what we're going
to be talking about this time is
essentially an ethical issue something
that was raised by D Snyder uh the front
man of of Twisted Sister and many other
things as well the question question is
what should bands be playing when
they're up on stage what should their
set list be what what duties do they
have to the fans to give deep tracks or
to give the the old fan favorites or
whatever else it's going to be that
they're going to be uh playing and and
bringing up so that's kind of an
interesting topic that we'll be
exploring uh then on the next day uh the
19th at uh uh oh actually on the same
day the 18th at 300 p.m. we're going to
shoot for doing a self-directed studies
uh video premiere releasing a video
specifically on Emmanuel Kant and if you
wanted to study him how would you best
go about doing that so if you're
interested in those that might be
helpful for you on the 19th that Sunday
at 2: p.m. I will be doing a story time
and this is going to be a double header
two HP Lovecraft stories set in the same
narrative Universe uh having some
characters in common first we'll do the
cats of olar and then we'll do the other
gods um both of which have one character
in common and then uh the following
weekend on the 25th uh at noon I'll be
doing understanding anger 2.0 uh this is
a session that we've had to put off
several times due to illnesses or just
general busyness and I'm going to be
talking about asus's the great Greek tra
tragedians uh Trilogy the oresta right
which starts out with the
Agamemnon and his uh killing by CTO
minestra and aises and then finishes
with arestes in Athens and being pursued
by the furies and the beginning of we
could say legal justice and how does
anger play out in all of those so we're
going to be doing that and then finally
another in-person event on the 30th at
6:00 pm at the Women's Club of Wisconsin
I will be doing another philosophy eats
session this is a dinner where I uh give
some enrichment some remarks some some
dialogue some uh topics of interest to
the participants and it's a fundraiser
for the Women's Club of Wisconsin uh
this time around understandably enough
the theme is gratitude what is it is it
a virtue is it a set of actions is it a
duty how should we understand it so
that'll be a fun one maybe I'll do some
some video work about that as well so
what else is going on in November as I
mentioned the third big big thing um I'm
going to be bringing out some online
classes certainly at least one that'll
be focused on platonic dialogues and so
you know keep an eye out for that I'll
be releasing a video about it I'll be
posting about it my social media and it
will be a class that you can you know
work at your own pace study on your own
with all the resources that I'll be
providing you I I really like designing
classes so you can tell I'm excited
about that um it's also of course this
month Thanksgiving here in America and
so I'm going to have my my kids around
um my youngest is coming up from Indiana
my oldest of course is here in town and
we'll be able to all get together
hopefully my dad will also come up and
we'll spend some time just hanging out
together having a great meal playing
Katan going to local Museum
coffee shops visiting the cat shelter
doing all those sorts of things that we
love to do um and then you know what am
I going to do as far as video Work Well
all those events you know will be video
recorded except for the philosophy eats
which maybe I'll do a video on anyway
and then um I've got more core concept
videos to do on IM manual cons pra to
any future metaphysics probably won't
fit finish the text in this month it'll
probably have to go into December but I
have also been shooting some videos on a
different text and a different author
Alistair McIntyre this really great
essay that he has how to seem virtuous
without actually being so which I use in
one of my ethics classes so I decided to
record a set of videos on that I've also
been kicking around the idea of doing
some speculative fiction studies videos
specifically on Jorge Lou bores some of
the stories that I love by him in
particular uh the lottery at Babylon the
library of Babel The Garden of forking
paths and we'll see what else I'm
actually up for I'll probably do some
Sadler stories videos because you know
I've got lots of stories to tell and
I'll you know do some other personal
videos perhaps and I'll try to do at
least one fake quotes video this month
and I got some momentum going with book
reviews I want to start doing more of
these book reviews because I've got lots
of books people have sent me kind of
piled up and needing to be reviewed um
I'm also going to be doing some ideas
that matter interviews this month I
didn't get to do any last month but this
coming month I've got a lot of great
guests that I want to uh bring in and
and talk uh with about various matters
that I think could be quite interesting
um podcast we're finishing up with
Aristotle's categories so you know by
the time that we're done we'll have
about 33 podcast episodes on that work
I've also got some for my business
ethics class on Robert Audi's really
excellent article um the ethical
significance of cost benefit analysis so
I've got a series that I've already
released to my patreon support ERS that
I will be releasing to the public and
then I've got to do some on Virginia
held and rosemary Tong's conception of
uh care ethics for some of my other
ethics classes I need some podcast
episodes on the you know uh topics from
my old videos on that and then I think
what I'll probably end up doing for the
next sequence of podcast episodes
probably won't finish it by the end of
the month is Ursa K Len's second Earth
sea novel The tombs of otan really
awesome short it's really more of a
Nolla than a novel but really great
Earth sea story so that is what we've
got coming up in November you can tell
uh quite ambitious there's a lot going
on we'll see how much I can actually get
done a lot of it depends on me remaining
at least as healthy as I feel
today uh which you never know how things
are going to turn out um so that is
everything that I have to put in front
of you I know it's quite a lot you can
find links to all these things Below in
the video description and I hope that I
see some of you at these online events
if you're here in the Milwaukee area and
you want to you know check out these
these other in-person events I'd be
happy to see you there if you do show up
you know make sure to introduce yourself
and I hope that you have a great month
ahead